that when you decided to end Seinfeld
you decided because Larry had already
left two years already left two years
earlier yeah seven years is a long time
for somebody to Executive produce a show
like that and that's a long time to
suffer the way I do in my daily life no
it wasn't burned out I had I had plenty
of ideas I thought I had done that and
now I I wanted to try something else and
that's that's pretty much it I just kind
of took over I worked twice as hard as I
would take three guys and they would be
Larry no I I don't no I don't regret it
I I missed it I missed everybody I
wanted to be happy but not too happy yes
it was very different I mean I didn't
know if I could continue the show I
really was pretty scared about it we
killed ourselves to make those shows as
good as they were they weren't we
weren't just hanging around people are
saying why don't you do another sitcom
and I think if I could do another sitcom
that good yeah I'm sure I'm sure I'd do
it you can't I mean I can't